[موسيقى]
اراد اسد الغابه الايقاع بين الضباع
والثعالب فراح يترك لها بقايا طعامه
لتختلف عليها ونجح فحشد كل فريق انصاره في
الغابه لحرب شعواء ادارها الاسد عن بعد
لكنه امر بعد اسبوعين بالتهدئة
على البحر
الميت خدام لا يلوم نفسه على شيء ولا يكره
حافظ الاسد فهو رفيق
العمر تغطيات ميدانيه للتلفزيون
الاسرائيلي في الموصل بمواكب
امنيه ممثل دور ابو جهل في ذمه الله واباء
الجهل العرب بصحه
[موسيقى]
جيده مرحبا مع ان محور الممانعه لديه حدود
مع الكيان الاسرائيلي من سوريا ومن لبنان
ومن داخل فلسطين نفسها لكن احمد جبريل
حبكت معه على الاردن هدد بان قوى الممانعه
ستدخل الاردن لتحرير فلسطين سواء وافق
الملك ام لم يوافق نحن سندخل الاردن سوا
رضي الملك او لم يرضى يا ساتر يا رب الملك
عبد الله عرف كيف في هذا الامر و ستقوم
ستكون المعركه شامله مع هذا العدو ما حدا
مانع الناس تقاوم داخل فلسطين تفضلوا
قاوموا يقول القيادي في فتح جمال محيسن
فكيف يرد عليه ارشيف الرئيس محمود عباس
عندما تدخل مجموعات خاصه اسرائيليه من اجل
اعتقال في منطقه الف انا بقول مين منع
الناس انه تتصدى له القوه الاحتلال اي
واحد بشوف اي واحد حامل صاروخ يضربه يقتله
يطخه منيح هيك مين منع الناس انه تتصدى
لهي القوه الاحتلال التنسيق الامني
مقدس مقدس الحاج زياد ابو هليل مسن
فلسطيني لا يحتاج الى اذن مقاومه من احد
وهو تصدى بعصا وبما تيسر من عباءته لجنود
الاحتلال اثناء قمعهم مسيره سلميه في
مدينه
الخليل لا ما بسمح لك تقتل ولا واحد ولا
دخ على واحد بدك تدخ دخ انا عل الرايب رام
الله وب شبال النار وعقال العز عقالك عزم
واسرار علي الرايب رام الله وبجب النار
واقال العز عقالك عزم اسرار والطلقه
الاولى فيها حكايه مشوار والطلقه الاولى
فيها حكايه مشوار عند الحق نخلي العالي
واطيها عند الحق نخلي العالي
هذا بالنسبه للشيوخ لكن ماذا عن اطفال
فلسطين هل اسرائيل موجوده في ادمغتهم صدمه
تلقتها القناه الثانيه الاسرائيليه اثناء
اجرائها تحقيقا مع تلامذه المدارس يشبه
التحقيقات الامنيه في المعتقلات وكيف سمح
اصلا بهذه
الاستجوابات هي خرطه خرطه اسرائيل هذا لا
فطين فلسطين مش اسرائيل
فلين لا اعترف اسرائيل لانها بلد محتله
موجوده هنا في في الكتب في الخريطه في
الخرائط الخرائط في الكتب لا هي مش موجوده
وكان الفلسطينيين في غزه والضفه يعيشون
على الكافيار وسومو فيمي حتى يعلن رئيس
الحكومه رامي حمد الله من كوكب اخر رح
ناكل العدس والبصل ولن نتراجع دخيلك رامي
بيك وين العدس والبصل حتى لو منجع وبنعيش
على العدس والبصل
لن نتراجع عدس بصر رحمه ونعمه في مصر بدا
موالون للنظام يهولون على المواطنين باكل
الحشرات حتى يرضوا بالفول الناس في الصين
بتاكل
الحشرات
بيعملوها جريل نحمد ربنا طب ناكل فول ولا
نبقى زي رو سوريا قاضي قضاه فلسطين محمود
الهباش وصف مؤتمر فلسطيني الخارج الذي
انعقد في اسطنبول بمؤتمر الشيطان مع انه
لم يشارك فيه وقد كانت قائمه الغياب طويله
بهذا المعنى المؤتمر الذي عقدوه في
اسطنبول او الذي سيعقدون في
اسطنبول مؤتمر
الفرقه مؤتمر الشيطان هو ليه دايما
الشيطان لازم يبقى اقرا وحواجبه تخينه
ولزقه في بعض بيكون صوته
كده ليه ما هي انواع برامج التلفزيون التي
تتابعونها اجابات على الماشي كل الحاجات
اللي تخص العالم الياض اخبار احداث ما
بقيتش اابع التلفزيون اصلا محطات
الحيوانات ولا شيء ما بتابعه ما بتفرج
الافلام امريكيه بتابع البرامج السياسيه
المسلسلات هذا بالنسبه للشباب اما بالنسبه
للرئيس محمود عباس فمن البرامج المتابعه
عنده ارب ايدول هكذا ابلغ المطربه احلام
اثناء عقده اجتماعا معها في بيروت
متابعك
مع توصلني
اخبارك ماعرف
اسرارك توصلني اخبارك
وظن اسرار يقولون انت
بتندب علي وعايش بنارك علي وعايش
ب مواطن يمني غضب من فوز المتسابق
الفلسطيني على زميله اليمني في التصفيات
فحطم جهاز التلفزيون صارخا محمود عباس 50
سنه يفاوض على القدس وبالاخر ياخذ الارب
ايدول في
لقاء محمود عباس له 50 سنه فاوض على القدس
وجا اخذ عرب ايدول في لقاء واحد عزيزي من
جعل الفلسطيني شاهين يربح الارب ايدول هو
ان الناس صوتت له ارادته وعندما ستريد
الناس القدس ستربح
دون مفاوضات ال 50 سنه اللي تحدثت
عنها السفير اليمني في بيروت استقبل نجوم
ارب ايدول في التصفيات الفلسطينيين
واليمني عمل من واجبهم والحلو الليي فيه
انه خزن كلمه ترحيبيه على الورقه والقاها
عليهم بكل مسؤوليه وعلى طريقه حكام
البرنامج صحيح انه لابد في الختام من
تسميه واحد كفائز بلقب ايدول بالنسبه
لكثيرين فان وصولكم للحلقه النهائيه هو
بمثابه فوز لكم جميعا اتمنى لكم جميعا
التالق والنجاح واهلا بكم مره اخرى رسلا
للفن
والمحبه السفير من هذه الجهه اما من الجهه
الاخرى الحوثيون مركزين على القداحات
الولاعات كسلاح استراتيجي في المعارك وما
حدا قادر يفهم ايش السر بين الحوثيين
والولاعات شو في بيناتهم لدينا في الارشيف
في قناه المسيره
ربما عشرات المشاهد للجيش واللجان الشعبيه
عندما اقتحموا موقع سعودي احد الجنود كان
يقول لزميله اين القداحه بلغه هنا القداحه
الولاعه قبل ان يغادروا او وهم يبحثون
عنما يفجروا به الاليات السعوديه يقاله
اين الولاعه او اين القداحه
اسرع اسرع فاحضرها زميله وهو كان قد جهز
قطعه كرتونه فاشعل وادخلها تحت الاليه
السعوديه وحتى اضمان عليها انها بدات
تحترك غادروها الموقع ح
حر حريقه حرقه حريقه اصحى اصحى الله يخرب
بيتك حريقه بالارج رد رئيس الحكومه
الاردنيه هاني الملقي على مظاهرات سارت في
شوارع عمان ضد غلاء الاسعار وطالبت برحيله
فتداول ناشطون صوره يبدو انه تعمد تسريبها
ويظهر فيها الملقي مستلقي على كرسي
استجمام مؤجلا مستمتعا بشمس الاغوار في
منطقه البحر الميت هاني الملقي يا عيوني
من نص العقبه
شوفوني الله يسعد اهل العجبه النائب صداح
الحباشنه صدح في وجه الملقي تحت قبه
البرلمان متهما اياه بتدمير البلاد انت يا
ملق رائح الدهور البلد انت رايح تقضى
علينا تقضى على الشعب الاردني ارحم الشعب
الاردني انا بقول لك ارحم الشعب الاردني
انت من اول ما جيت كل مصايب البلد من وراك
اتقي الله يا رج يعني احنا طباخين ابنا عن
جد وحضرتك وزير اب عن جد وبينما كان
الملقي يستجم على البحر الميت كان سائح
امريكي يوجه له وللمسؤولين
الحكوميين رساله غاضبه يطلب فيها تنظيف
المراحيض في العقبه وجرش وسائر المناطق
السياحيه نظف نظف العقب
نبط نيف وما شاء الله
عليها
لولا المساعدات الماليه العربيه لما
استطاع نظام حافظ الاسد ان يقف على رجليه
عبد الحليم خدام يعترف لعلي الظفيري سوريا
المساعدات
العربيه وقفت سوريا على
رجات طبعا المساعدات العربيه لم تكن تاتي
من موريتانيا ولا من مصر ولا من لبنان ولم
يكن نظام حافظ الاسد ارح من نظام بشار مع
شعب سوريا ولبنان فلماذا اوقفت الدول
العربيه المانحه مساعداتها لبشار واغد قها
على والده اذا كانت غيرتها على الشعب
السوري فالنظام هو واحد
بفصلين سئلت احدى الفنانات الاستعراضيات
ذات مره ما هي اسوا صفاتك فاجابت طيبه
قلبي وسئل خدام في برنامج المقابله هل
يلوم نفسه على شيء
فكيف اجاب بتلوم حالك انت كنت نائب رئيس
وشريك في السلطه انا شريك بالسلطه
بالسياسه الخارجيه سياده الخارجيه نجحت
يعني رجعت
لسوريا موقعها الطبيعي شو بتحتفظ ذاكرتك
مع حافظ الاسد محبه احترام غبن كراهيه شو
موضع الكراهيه لا
لاني شخص بعرفه من لم كنا طلاب
ابو جمال كانت فرصه لك لتعتذر عن عشرات
الوف المظلومين الذين شاركت في ظلمهم يا
اخي فقط في لبنان حيث كنت الحاكم او مساعد
الحاكم في احسن الاحوال هناك 150 الف اتيل
لبناني وفلسطيني في الحرب شو بتحسب عليك
منهم ابلان ماشي الحال بس ولا شيء شو كنت
سفير النوايا الحسنه انت بلبنان انظر كيف
كان يمكن ان تكون اجابتك لولا من سب على
شيء ساب عليه بلوم حالي وهي
فرصه حتى اقدم
اعتزاري من ارواح ناس
رحلت ناس بعدها
عايشه اولا بدي اعتذر من الشعب السوري
المظلوم اللي انا سهمت
بظلمه بدي اعتذر من منظمه تحرير
فلسطينيه ابناء المخيمات
بلبنان بدي اعتذر من الشعب
اللبناني والجيش اللبناني اللي
قسمناه بدي اعتذر من مدن زحله
طرابلس بدي اعتذر من الاف
الضحايا اعتذاري يمكن ما يغير لهم شي بس
غيرلي شيء كثير لي
بعتذر
ستيفان د مستورا هل سيرقص على الطاوله
رئيس منصه استان التفاوضيه رندا قسيس لم
تستبعد ذلك في اطار هجومها على د مستورا
بسبب استبعاده اياها عن محادثات الجناب
كان يتكلم عن الطاولات هنا طاوله وهناك
طاوله يحب ان يرقص على الطاولات هلا لا
اعرف اذا كان يريد ان يرقص فوق الطاوله او
يدور حول الطاوله وهذا ما يفعله حقيقه
استفان مستوره النظام الامريكي الجديد لم
يتسع صدره للشباب السوريين المزع فين
المعروفين بالخوض البيضاء فمنع دخولهم
الولايات المتحده ومشاركتهم في حفل
الاوسكار الذي حصدت فيه قصتهم جائزه
الفيلم السينمائي الوثائقي فيلم الخوذات
البيضاء انتزع جائزه الاوسكار عن فئه افضل
موضوع لوثائقي قصير وقد كان ينافسه وثائقي
عن الهولوكوست
واشنطن منعت فريق فيلم الخوذات البيضاء من
دخول الولايات المتحده فتل مخرج الفيلم
كلمه نيابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عنهم ان منظمتنا تعمل استنادا الى ايه من
القران تقول ومن احياها فكانما احيا الناس
جميعا ونحن انقذنا حياه اكثر من 882 الف
سوري لكل من يشكك بالسياده السوريه دعوه
مفتوحه من الخبير الاستراتيجي حسن حسن
لدخول الحمام
والاختلاء
والتامل كل ما له علاقه بما يتعلق بسياده
الدوله السوريه على كامل التراب السوري
185000 ك م مربع هذا شان سيادي خاص
بالدوله السوريه وكل كل من يفكر بغير ذلك
عليه ان يدخل باختصار شديد على الحمام
يسكر الحمام عليه ويحكي بينه وبين حلو هذا
الحكي خيو شو بده يساع هالحمام ل يساع يا
رجل الايرانيون انفسهم يتحدثون على نفوذهم
في بغداد ودمشق وبيروت النائب علي رضا
مثالا وليس حصرا اعلن علي رضا زاكاني احد
اعضاء البرلمان الايراني مؤخرا ان طهران
تبسط نفوذها على ثلاث دول عربيه هي بيروت
ودمشق ثم بغداد اسرائيل استفادت من
انهزامها في لبنان بحسب نائب حزب الله
السابق نزيه منصور ويحاول الكيان الصهيوني
ان يشغل المنطقه فيما بينها وهو وقد
استفاد من من حرب تموز التي هزم بها وهو
قد استفاد من من حرب تموز التي هزر
[موسيقى]
بها من هو السياسي الاول في الشرق الاوسط
سؤال وجهته الكاميرا على السريع لبعض
المواطنين في عمان والله ما في سياسي اول
زي الملك حسين اردوغان ما بعرف انت ادرى
هو السيسي عبد الفتاح السيسي لنل هبابي
النائبه العراقيه راي اخر فالسياسي الاول
في الشرق الاوسط عندها هو ابو اسراء نوري
نوري المالكي كثير من الدول اعتبر السيد
المالكي الرجل السياسي رقم واحد في الشرق
الاوسط بعد احفاد جون احفاد بن جوريون في
الموصل الصحفي في القناه الاسرائيليه
الثانيه ايتاي انجل يرافق القوات العراقيه
لاعداد تقارير ميدانيه في مدينه الموصل
[موسيقى]
في المقابل كان الصحفيون العراقيون
يتعرضون للتعنيف وتكسير الكاميرات ورئيس
الحكومه حيدر العبادي يسارع الى تكذيبهم
تفاجانا باعتداء عل
من قبل اكثر من 30 فرد من افراد حمايات
وتم كسر كاميرتي وفقدان بعض
الاجهزه فلاي اطالبه من سيادتك اولا
تعويضي بما تم خسارتي افتح تحقيق في هذا
الموضوع انا لا اصدق هذا الكلام حمايتي مو
بالخارج موجودين عدد قليل من الحمايه كان
معي نعم كان معي واكو اعلاميين موجودين
انا لا افهم كيف انا اتصور انت التحقت
باولئك اللي كسروا اللي كسروا كاميرتك
عينين مفتوحتين اكد الامين العام لميليشيا
الخرساني علي الياسري ان ايران لا تتدخل
في العراق بخلاف السعوديه يجيك السفير
السعودي ويتجاوز ويسب ويتدخل في شؤون
العراقيه هذا مو صحيح احنا ما شفنا وزير
خارجيه ايراني او سفير ايراني دخل في
الشان
العراقي حجم الفيديوهات التي يمكن ان ترد
على الياسري يحتاج الى سنه من البث
المتواصل لكن دعونا اولا نستمع الى علي
الياسر نفسه كيف يرد على نفسه في اللقاء
نفسه من سيحدد موقفكم بالذهاب الى سوريا
من عدمه عزيزي حيث ما اقتضت المصلحه وحيث
ما من يحدد المصلحه بس هو هذا السؤال
غيرتنا كعراقيين جيد ولكن اكو سيا دول
مسلمين كشي كعاملين في مجال المقاومه حيث
ما يقتضي الامر سنكون هناك وحتى لو ما
وافقت الدوله العراقيه
اقول احنا الدوله العراقيه مو هي اللي
شكلت خراساني فرقه خارج الحكومه ولواء
داخل الحكومه استاذ علي حتى الحكومه اصبحت
ايران تحدد رئاستها بحسب رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق اياد علاوي ايران هي اليوم الكل
يتحدث انه هي الحاكم الفعلي لحك ماخالف
عندها نفوذ كبير هي مازال هذا النفوذ بهذا
الح لا انت تعرفين حضرتك يعني هم بال 2010
وغيرها ووراها وقبلها هم يحددون من يصير
رئيس وزراء ثم اين المشكله التي تريد ان
تهرب منها استاذ علي اذا سيطرت ايران على
العراق هل انت ضد التكليف الشرعي علي
يونسي مستشار الرئيس الايراني يعلن ايران
اليوم اصبحت امبراطوريه كما كانت عبر
التاريخ وعاصمتها بغداد حاليا اعترف نائب
قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني الجنرال حسين
سلامي بوجود جماعات مسلحه العراق وسوريا
واليمن مرتبطه بنظام طهران علي الياسري
يقول ايضا امريكا شر مطلق ومقدم البرنامج
يرد عليه شر مطلق وهو من اتى بكم على ظهر
دباباته لتحكموا العراق يعني انت تعتقد ان
الامريكان شر مطلق يعني اكيد طيب ما
الامريكان هم اللي خلوا الشيعه حكام
العراق سواء كان الامريكان موجودين او غير
موجودين فلا بد اذا الشعب يوما اراد
الحياه
كيف تقدم ايران الاستشارات العسكريه
للعراق الذي هزمها في الحرب يسال الناطق
الرسمي السابق باسم احمد الجلبي انتفاض
قمبر المتخوف على مصير لسنه العراق
كالهنود الحمر انا اعتقد من المهين
والمعيب نقول مستشارين ايرانيين علمونا
ليش احنا بالحرب العراقيه الايرانيه ثمان
سنين دمرناهم ومن جمله اللي ان جرحوا 12
و1 مره قاسم سليماني يعني الضباط
العراقيين اللي دمروا الجيش الايراني
يجيبون اللي هم دمروهم يعلموهم شلون
يحاربون هي ايران ش وقت حاربت ايران
تاريخها مو حاره روحي على تاريخ ايران 400
سنه ما داخله ولا حرب الطبقه السياسيه
الحاكمه في ايران اليوم كلهم حتى وزير
خارجهم كلهم من جيل الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه وكلهم ماكلين كتل من الجيش
العراقي وكلهم حاقدين على العراق
الايرانيين يدون يسوون السنه مثل الهنود
الحمر شلون يعني يعني يقسمو
وحطوهم بمخيمات ويعزلهم ودمرهم لانه
الايرانيين يرون في سنه العراق خطر
استراتيجي
[موسيقى]
عليهم ميسي زار مصر لساعات قليله فتفوق
موكبه الامني على موكب السيسي في زياره
ترويجيه للسياحه العلاجيه في مصر وتحديدا
في حمله علاج فيروس سي فما علاقه كل ذلك
بجهاز الكفته كسفير لعلاج فيروس سي ازاي
انت بتفيد هذه الحمله الكبيره باخذ المرض
من مريض بديه له صبع كفته يتغذى عليه وهذا
قمه الاعجاز العلمي ولكن ايضا انت بتقدر
انك تساعد الناس اللي مريضه بالمرض ده في
الارجنتين وفي بوليفيا ايضا اقسم بالله
لاجيب امريكا تتعالج في مصر برزت في زياره
ميسي للقاهره مقابلته مع الاعلامي عمرو
اديب التي رفض فيها ميسي ترديد عباره انا
احب مصر ايه رايك بالاهرامات اهرامات اوه
يس الاهرامات جميله جدا لقد درسناها في
المدرسه ايه هو شكل الاهرامات يا ترى مثلث
مربع او دائري ارجوك اعطيتك من وقتي
دقيقتين ل تسالني عن الاهرامات هسالك
دلوقتي السؤال القوي هل احببت اكثر
الملوخيه بالارانب او الكشري ملوخيه احببت
الملوخيه اكثر فاذا ما تكلش ملوخيه وتلعب
كوره
تاني بليز ارجوك انهي هذه المقابله فورا
ماشي ممكن تقول انا بحب مصر اي لاف
ايجيب اوكي اوكي ايجيبت خلاص ماشي كلمه
اخيره للشعب المصري يس ش انا اتمنى ان
اكون قد تمكنت من ايصال الرساله حول حجم
خطر روس سي سيروس سي يا ب نعم سي سياني
هتودينا في داهيه يا ميسي ده فيروس سي ومش
سيسي ممثل دور ابو جهل في فيلم الرساله
رحل تاركا وراءه الكثيرين ممن يؤدون دور
ابو جهل في الواقع والمواقع بكل امانه
وتفوق ان النفوس العاليه يرحل محمد حسن
الجندي لكن لقب ابو جهل وصفعه حمزه ما
تزال ترتسم في مخيله كل منا ها نحن اليوم
يودع قامه سينمائيه ثقيله عن عمر يناهز 79
عاما يرحل ابن مراكش والعرب وكل عاشق
للسينما فنحن عشيره واحده اكبر رؤساء
العالم الزمبابوي موجابي يحتفل بعيد
ميلاده
ال3 ويؤكد انه لن يتدخل في تحديد وريث
حكمه موجابي الذي يحكم البلاد بقبضه
حديديه منذ استقلاله عن بريطانيا عام
1980 انه لن يفرض من سيخلفه في حكم
البلاد ختاما يروى ان شاعرا دخل على سلطان
وامتدح فاراد الاخير الاستجابه لحاجته
ساله ماذا يريد فقال الشاعر تامر قاضي
المدينه اذا وجدني سكرانا لا يقيم علي
الحد فقال له السلطان لا سبيل الى ترك
الحد لكننا لن نعدم مخرجا ف كتب السلطان
الى قاضي المدينه عندما يؤتى اليك بشاعرنا
هذا وهو سكران فاجلد 80 واجلد الذي جاءك
به 100 جلده فصار الشرطه يمرون عليه
ويقولون من يشتري 80 ب 100
ويتركونه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
لا